está el batallón de asof en capacidad de
realizar un atentado de este tipo porque
se podría pensar en lo divina como un
objetivo sumada a la muerte de oligarcas
rusos en los últimos meses y en
circunstancias extrañas
si es realmente un misterio bueno la
versión de que fue el fbi el servicio
inteligencia ucraniano es la acusación
por el fsb según servicio seguridad
federal ruso que es la principal
agencia sucesora de la antigua cajeme
soviética y bueno dicen que fue un
agente del fbi que con su hija había
estado siguiendo a daria dukina y que
después de cometer se la explosión pues
europa a través de pskov ciudad
fronteriza rusa a estonia pero el punto
es que él según parece el automóvil iba
a ser conducido por alexander dogging el
padre de daria rubina y que en el último
momento pues él decidió manejar el otro
vehículo que presuntamente era el que
manejaba a su hija cuando fueron un
evento estaban yéndose
y pues que manejó el vehículo del padre
o sea de alexánder doguín fue ella daria
y da la impresión por esa versión que la
bomba realmente iba dirigida contra
alexander dogging el ideólogo ideólogo
de la ideología post soviética del neo
eurasian ismo realmente es una ideología
que surgió entre los emigrados rusos de
la rusia zarista una vez que lenin y la
revolución bolchevique toman posesión
pues de rusia pero volvía a resurgir
como una alternativa ultra nacionalista
rusa una razón de ser ideológica tras la
caída de la unión soviética en el 91 y
la el vacío ideológico con la caída el
marxismo leninismo entonces el
negacionismo básicamente considera que
rusia no tiene que imitar occidente en
la democracia liberal en una economía de
mercado en que el sector privado es
fuerte sino debe seguir su propio camino
también filosófico espiritual porque
occidente es inferior a rusia y rusia
del producto de la mezcla de la
civilización de lava y turco mongol a
ese derecho disculpa profesor que la
interrumpa pero es que quisiera
continuar hablando un poco de duhalde
este cambio de último momento que
terminó con su vida
ella era comentarista habitual de medios
rusos y además con usted lo dice pues
nada más y nada menos que la hija del
ideólogo tuvo inquina y que además
estaba a favor de reunificar la extinta
unión soviética
este crimen sucede solamente dos días
antes de la celebración del día de la
bandera en ucrania que recuerda la
independencia de los soviéticos hay
relación
podría ser podría ser también hay muchos
rumores se está diciendo por ejemplo que
fue un atentado
profesional y que ayer habrían sido los
servicios inteligencia rusos quienes
realmente lo habrían hecho podría ser
acaso un 'falso positivo' un
atentado de falsa bandera para cruzar a
ucrania y justificar una escalada de la
intervención se ha estado diciendo por
otra fuente del canal este de la red
social telegram un canal de oposición en
telegram la oposición al régimen de
putin que bueno que los allegados de
putin considera y exigen presionan a
vladimir putin que busquen una
alternativa una salida a la guerra una
guerra que habría costado estas alturas
64 mil muertos entre tropas regulares
que serían 48 mil muertos tropas
mercenarias del grupo wagner mercy mero
ruso más de 13 mil y pues tropas del
ministerio del interior y milicianos de
idónea esquí de lugares pro rusos en
1800 tanques destruidos etcétera
entonces dice que putin no tiene buenas
alternas estaría considerando según esta
fuente
o usar armas nucleares tácticas para
imponerse en ucrania o abrir un nuevo
frente contra otro país de la antigua
unión soviética miembro como kazajistán
ocupar el norte que la mayoría rusa
granjeros y agricultores rusos viven
allí
y pues al llegar de que bueno pues está
la guerra de ucrania pues como algo
aparte y está todavía en grande siendo a
rusia pero son rumores no está muy claro
yo diría que podría ser elementos
descontentos de putin de la inteligencia
que lo pudieron haber hecho para
eliminar a alguien que presuntamente
habría influenciado esa idea de la gran
rusia de la invasión de ucrania ya
incluso en 2014